let's hear from people in the audience
without you i'm a guy in a room with a
microphone talking to no one and it's
sad so that's why i want to hear from
the people we take calls via discord you
can find our discord at davidpakman.com
slash discord this could be interesting
let's go to
wasif wasif i can't see are you are you
from bangalore is that what it says
in bangladesh i'm from bangladesh
bangladesh beautiful welcome to the
program
yeah thank you uh uh
it's a pleasure to talk to you so i have
a very specific question i have been you
know like uh i'm someone who's you know
pretty much intrigued and interested in
overall you know let's say uh
international politics right and
especially u.s i think uh it is very
interesting so this is what i have you
know somewhat you know uh understood
regarding the landscape right now i see
you know we know that you know us has
two major you know like political
parties right but if i had to you know
divide the kind of people that are
currently in you know involved in
politics let's say mainstream you know
uh politicians who are you know working
for the government right so i see like
there are you know uh some very
pro-leftist you know the aoc and you
know the justice democrat types then you
have you know the
completely far-right wing type of people
you know most of them you know endorsed
by trump you can say trumpist and then
you have you know the typical status quo
you know middle of the ground you know
in in a lot of sense they might be you
know like libertarians and in foreign
policy they are more more or less like
neocons
and
right now you know like uh since we have
a war in ukraine and
there are a lot of issues you know
that is you know being generated by that
one and someone who is you know let's
say uh
anti-war
i think there is a chance that you know
like do you think it is possible uh for
the
you know the
the right-wing side you know more or
less the extreme side i would say and
the you know leftist side to
come to an agreement and you know form
some kind of coalition like the other
you know international countries where
they you know make sure that they can
form a coalition to get
the neocons out of power or something
like that i think here's this
this is very interesting wasif which is
there are there's this new kind of
anti-war right which is it was really
spurred by trump saying i'm going to
hillary will get us into wars but i
won't so you've got that contingent and
then you have the people like me on the
left who have been saying the us is too
involved globally in many cases we have
no right and no responsibility to go and
quote spread democracy so couldn't they
come together it's a beautiful idea
wasif but here's why i don't know that
it will work
the trumpists who claim to be against
war they're not really against war
they're for whatever trump tells them
they're supposed to be for and they will
on the one hand say
war is bad we're not gonna do it we're
not gonna do it and then at the same
time say whoa joe biden isn't doing
nearly enough in ukraine he should be
sending troops and he should be sending
drones so
they're not genuine in their opposition
to quote war they just want to be
contrarians and they want something to
be able to criticize democrats with uh
oh yeah i think you're right in that
sense but
like uh this is what i want to say you
know i think there is a side of you know
let's say you know the republican fan
base right
who is you know like somewhat you know
jumped on this bandage or you know of
antiwar especially you know after you
know tucker carlson is doing all those
stuff you know promoting you know uh
let's say
putin's favorable comments you know even
though you know
from a country like mine you know we
have you know strong ties you know more
or less with russia because uh they were
one of you know the soviet union were
one of the you know uh funding uh prime
allies who helped us
in our you know
independence yes but i would say that
you know in even in that scenario i
think you know
there has
been you know you know like i've been
feeling that you know there is a you
know significant uh possibility of
creating such a scenario where you have
you know people who are on the right but
they will you know at least oppose you
know uh let's say too much you know
getting involved in wars right and
[Music]
like i said you know uh i don't want to
you know uh
extend this question further but i think
there are some you know left-wing people
right now who are actually you know
getting involved with tucker right
some people come there call them you
know like let's say looney left or
something like that but no no i
understand i i i think i get the point
it's just a question of whether they
would really work together in a good
faith coalition or whether everybody's
really there you know for for their own
reasons
i think i think you know
for a country like you know us who is
you know like uh we have
people like us you know we we see you
know uh us getting too much involved in
war right i think
they should at least try to
you know do this idea like you know we
you know the right says you know let us
you know uh get some of our you know
compromise and you know left to make
some of their compromise and then you
know
the benefit will be getting the neo
comes out sure i think no understood
listen we've never had a call from
bangladesh before what's going on in the
background i'm so curious what are the
noises we hear where are you oh well my
house is pretty near the you know
somewhat main street i guess there is a
mosque nearby oh you know it's a muslim
majority country uh the only month of
ramadan is going on so you know people
are coming out of mosque basically and
you know the noises are from mosque
beautiful well listen i appreciate the
call thank you
um yeah we'll go all right there is
wasif from bangladesh compelling stuff
very very interesting
one of our longtime sponsors is vincero
collective if you don't know vincero yet
it's the place to go for quality watches
sunglasses and more
serious style
undeniable quality and total versatility
put vincero really at the top of the
game and their newest watch release
is no exception it's the argo automatic
it spotlights everything i love about
vincero i got the argo automatic in
frost white this is a dive watch which
is of course a staple in the watch world
but i really think vincero found a way
to make this one stand out i love the
gradient blue accent of the hour markers
against the solid white face i really
love all of their watches and i own a
bunch but the argo is probably my
favorite so far
vincero sunglasses and jewelry and other
accessories are awesome too
an excellent way to elevate any outfit
vincero collective is giving my audience
15 off all products and free shipping go
to vincerocollective.com
pacman and use the code pacman the link
is down below